là messieurs bonsoir la chute d'un aigle
mohamed de reza pahlavi empereur d'iran
depuis 37 ans a quitté ce matin son pays
son retour est plus qu'hypothétique
c'est les larmes aux yeux que le shah
d'iran et son épouse ont quitté téhéran
ce matin peu avant 1 heure française je
ne sais pas quand je rentrerai a dit le
chat ça dépend de mon état de santé et
fidèle se jeter alors sur son passage
pour empêcher son départ
le chat [ __ ] on serrait sur sa poitrine
un petit coffret dans lequel ils
emportaient de la terre d'iran c'est
assez dire qu'il avait peu d'espoir de
ne jamais la foulée à nouveau quelques
heures plus tard son avion atterrissait
à assen où l'accueillait anouar el
sadate dans un geste qui ne manque pas
de noblesse à un moment où le monde
entier lâche le souverain iranien et
l'accueil enthousiaste des égyptiens
tranche singulièrement avec l'explosion
de joie qui s'est emparée de l'iran dès
que la rumeur du shah d'iran s'est
amplifiée sur place pour en juger
atterrant edwards lors il aura fallu à
peine une heure une heure après le
décollage de l'avion du la propulsant
1200 milles peut-être le temps milieu
rania descendent dans les rues de
téhéran pour purger leur joie dans un
délire indescriptible
la nouvelle s'est propagée à travers la
capitale a eu cet incroyable quelques
heures après que la radio est a lancé
officiellement le départ du genre je le
trouvais à ce moment là en plein centre
de la ville pour coin ses deux plus
grandes artères de téhéran va la vie et
chats raisin et là quelques minutes et
tous les visages se transforme et les
moins jeunes se mettra sur les des
voitures et castle bloqué vers 4h image
symbolique une révolution la première
est lui tombé
c'était celle du père du genre hurlera
trois autres quelques instants plus tard
sur différentes places de téhéran
une ville où il n'existe pratiquement
pas et n'auront pas une avenue
pas un seul édifice public il porte le
nom de l'un ou de lui de la finale
qu'ils aient pas là
et c'est cette liesse populaire qui rend
difficile voire improbable un retour du
chat dont on dit qu'il pourrait après
l'egypte faire une escale au maroc en
europe peut-être avant de s'installer
définitivement californie où se trouvent
déjà tout le reste de sa famille et
cette joie populaire qui a embrasé tout
l'iran aujourd'hui
eh bien on l'a retrouvé à une toute
petite échelle dans une modeste villa de
la banlieue parisienne à
neauphle-le-château au pc de l'ayatollah
khomeini serge me serais était aux côtés
de l'ail est là lorsqu'il a appris le
départ de son ennemi mortel
le reportage donc de serge me serais qui
était à neauphle le château et bien sûr
portage vous ne pourrez pas le voir tout
de suite je pense que pourra vous dire
que cet homme de 78 ans donc
l'ayatollah khomeiny qui venait pourtant
de gagner le combat de sa vie
et bien cet homme est resté impassible
pendant tout l'entretien sur sa petite
chaise de bois
et pendant ce temps un autre ayatollahs
l'un des chefs religieux les plus
écoutées d'iran l'ayatollah taleghani
invitait la population à garder le calme
et à préserver l'ordre et la discipline
alors viens maintenant bien sûr le temps
des questions on se les posent en nous
essaierons de ne jamais oublier que le
chat n'a pas abdiqué officiellement et
que c'est un conseil de régence composé
de neuf membres désignés par le chat lui
même son départ qui reste garante de la
continuité de la monarchie à période
n'oublions pas non plus que l'armée est
toujours là le gouverneur militaire de
téhéran l'a même fait sentir très
fortement ce soir en annonçant par
avance la répression de toute actes
d'agitation
alors quel va être le poids respectif de
cette armée du premier ministre de
l'opposition religieuse et l'opposition
laïque
la réponse sur place d'abord des doigts
eh bien je crois qu'il faut dès ce soir
dès maintenant poser un certain nombre
de questions formulées à certain nombre
d'hypothèses qui peuvent se résumer en
un seul point d'interrogation qui
gouvernera l'iran demain je crois qu'il
y a trois possibilités
3 non l'actuel premier ministre bastia
avec un gouvernement un peu faible qui a
reçu l'investiture de l'assemblée dans
l'indifférence générale et qui a à mon
avis deux handicaps
celui d'avoir l'appui des américains ce
n'est pas très bien vu aujourd'hui en
iran et surtout celui d'avoir été nommé
par le chat c'est encore moins bien vu
deuxième non l'ayatollah khomeini s'il
revient en iran il ya en fait deux
possibilités il prend la tête d'un
gouvernement d'union nationale mais
malheureusement on ne voit pas très bien
avec qui où il prend lui-même la tête
comme premier ministre d'un gouvernement
islamique et beaucoup pensent qu'à la
limite
dans l'état actuel ou et l'iran autant
aller jusqu'au bout pourquoi pas
troisième et dernière possibilité les
militaires c'est le grand point
d'interrogation
soit ils appuient le gouvernement actuel
de monsieur bakhtiar ce serait un mini
coup d'état soit ils soutiennent un
éventuel retour de l'ayatollah khomeini
soit ils prennent directement le pouvoir
par un coup d'état
en tout cas il y une chose qui est
certaine il faudra demain à l'iran un
gouvernement très fort pour essayer de
remonter une crise économique qui depuis
six mois fait que l'iran ait dans
l'anarchie la plus complète une bataille
est perdue mais la guerre n'est pas
terminée disais tout à l'heure un est du
camp du chat sur l'aéroport de téhéran
c'est un point de vue bien sûr mais que
dément un homme qui fut proche du chat
et qui depuis s'est éloigné de lui son
ancien ambassadeur à moscou
quelles sont les chances du gouvernement
bakhtiar a terrain je ne crois pas à la
grande chose de pouvoir du raid étant
donné la position politique dans le pays
alors qui prendra la tête du
gouvernement l'ayatollah khomeini je ne
crois pas et même il vise une telle
situation
louis je crois elle envisage de guider
n'est ce pas le déroulement de la
situation politique en irak pour le
bien-être de la population
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer dans
les prochaines semaines selon vous est
ce que les partisans du ch avons vont
essayer de provoquer le retour du
souverain savez le change
selon mon avis
aucun partisan ira les américains en
tête toujours son appui dès le début
avait imposé par la cia
il est parti parce que n'est plus ne
sert plus les plus de 6 ans qui a perdu
dix ans joue donc en ce qui concerne les
iraniens et n'a pas de partition il ya
au moins les chefs militaires qui ne
provoqueront pas un coup d'état pour le
faire revenir
oui il faut pas confondre les chefs
militaires avec l'armée il ya des chefs
militaires bien sûr qui ont participé au
pillage du pays pendant très longtemps
qu'ils étaient d'accord avec la
monarchie du actuelle mais ils ne
peuvent pas diriger des opérations parce
que vraisemblablement l'armée et les
jeunes officiers ne sont pas fait sûr de
suivre
est ce qu'il ya un risque de guerre
civile il n'ya rien d'exclu
malheureusement en irak tout dépend sur
la diplomatie américaine mais elle est
difficile de prévoir à cause d éducation
de capteurs les divergences de ses
conseillers alors tout est possible mais
ce qui est sûr c'est que un coup dur
militaire ne sera pas favorable à la
longue vous intérêts de l'amérique en
iran selon vous c'en est fini de la
monarchie en iran la monarchie n'a
aucune chance en iran n'est ce pas un
avenir s'ils veulent imposer de me
lâcher quoi que ce soit ils vont aller
vers un échec total
vous pensez que le fils du chah le jeune
prince héritier ne règnera pas ça veut
dire de bois vous savez en iran ce
younès
le peuple de l'iran de choisir librement
c'est absolument exclu vas-y maintenant
comme promis la réaction de l'ayatollah
khomeini réaction qui vous le verrez
tranche avec l' enthousiasme de ses
partisans qui l'entourent à
neauphle-le-château les parties
l'ayatollah qui sont venus nombreux à
neauphle-le-château laissent éclater
leur joie
ils viennent d'apprendre le départ du
shah longue vie à chromé nikitine est
une république islamique pour yves haby
eilat et l'ayatollah peut savourer son
triomphe son principal ennemi l'homme
qui l'a exilé vient à son tour de
prendre le chemin de l'exil et la presse
du monde entier l'a suspendu aux paroles
du chef religieux et toutes premières
sont adressés au peuple iranien et à sa
lutte héroïque qui l'ayatollah le peuple
iranien qui vient de remporter une
grande victoire
ce premier il la vraie victoire ce sera
la fin de la domination étrangère sur le
pays
ce sont là des paroles de situation le
plus important le leader religieux l'a
dit quelques heures auparavant dans un
communiqué qui rappelle sa position le
gouvernement bastia est il légal illégal
aussi le conseil de régence installé par
le chas seule reconnue et le conseil
provisoire de la révolution islamique
qui serait en ce moment mais en ce
moment même en train d'opérer en iran
ainsi et comme on pouvait s'y attendre
la position de la de l'ayatollah n'a pas
varié d'un pouce
pour conclure il a appelé la population
iranienne à une grande manifestation
pour le 19
après quoi eh bien il est allé comme
d'habitude faire ces actions de grâces
pour lui la fin de l'exil un proche
quand rentrera-t-il en iran c'est une
question à laquelle pour le moment il ne
veut pas répond michel planes de ski sur
notre antenne à midi apporte un
éclairage sur la situation précisément
de l'ayatollah khomeini ce sont les
iraniens eux mêmes at il dit qui ne
souhaitait pas qu'une mesures sévères
soient prises en france à son encontre
michel panier de ski qui semble avoir
lui-même négocier l'arrivée de
l'ayatollah khomeini en france
pas de réaction officielle américaine
à noter qu'on vient d'apprendre que le
chef des conseillers militaires
américains en iran avait été trouvé
pendu dans sa maison de téhéran mais on
ne sait pas si le collège à note s'est
suicidé ou si on la tue voilà je crois
que toute l'information qui nous est
arrivé minute par minute sur nos
téléscripteurs aujourd'hui il nous reste
quand même à retracer la carrière de
celui qui fut l'âme et le chef de l'iran
pendant près de 40 ans mais comme le
document que nous avons préparée et très
complet un quart d'heure en tout je
propose de le regarder tout à fait à la
fin de ce journal et je voulais tout de
suite qu'il est de toute beauté
en attendant je vous invite à écouter le
souverain iranien dans la dernière
interview qu'il nous avait accordée il
ya deux mois à peine et l écoute de ce
document à l'époque nous nous étions
tous dit cet homme est finie regardez
l'intensité que l'on trouvait dans les
silences et dans les réponses du chat
aux questions de edward l'impression est
un peu déçu majesté de tenter de faire
quelque chose pour votre pays et
peut-être pas être compris de tous seuls
non pas tellement je crois j'ai toujours
été très mystique
je crois que je dois accomplir quelque
chose et
rien d'autre ne m'intéresse que le croit
ce que ce que j'ai fait en rapport avec
ma destinée est ce que ce qui avait été
décidé que je fasse
oh la la
voilà donc je vous le répète rendez vous
me le confirme à la fin du journal pour
un document sur le chat dont nous ne
craignons pas de dire qu'il est
exceptionnel le reste de l'actualité
maintenant à commencer d'abord par
l'annoncé de créations d'emplois dans
les régions en difficulté en france
depuis quelques mois
savoir le nord pas de calais la lorraine
la basse loire et la région marseillaise
créations d'emplois annoncées par le
premier ministre raymond barre le miz
l'industrie andré giraud et le délégué à
l'aménagement du territoire
andré chad 11 1620 poids en tout dont
près de 10000 dans l'industrie et ce ni
6,3 sur les neuf mille huit cents
emplois industriels créer grâce au fonds
spécial d'adaptation les deux tiers le
seront dans l'automobile les emplois
restants étant des emplois tertiaires
au total le fonds aura engagé en quatre
mois 800 millions de francs
le quart de ces critiques premier
régions bénéficiaires le nord pas de
calais avec six mille huit cents emplois
notamment dans le valenciennois en tête
l'implantation dès le 1er mars prochain
d'une usine de boîtes de vitesses par le
groupe peugeot-citroën extension de l'
usine de moteurs de la française de
mécanique à douvrin
et puis importante aussi la
décentralisation dans la métropole
lilloise de plusieurs services
administratifs de la sncf deuxième
région les ardennes mille emplois du en
totalité à l'extension d'une usine de
fonderie de peugeot citroën dans la zone
charleville mézières troisièmement la
lorraine un peu plus de 900 emplois
grâce surtout à une usine de batteries
d'auto créé à sarreguemines par general
motors
quatrièmement la basse-loire 1600
emplois moitié électronique moitié
administration avec surtout la
décentralisation du service des pensions
du ministère du budget cinquième région
l'est marseillais 13 cents emplois
numéro un ici une usine de circuits
intégrés installés par saint gobain près
d'aubagne
au total grâce aux subventions et aux
prêts publics qui s'ajoutent aux
capitaux privés
c'est donc onze mille six cents emplois
qui seront créés entre 1981 et 1984 ce
que l'on peut dire c'est que le fonds
spécial d'adaptation industrielle n'est
n'est qu'après le débat sidérurgique au
sénat c'est à dire la fin du mois de
novembre et que c'est donc disons 4 mois
parce qu'il avait commencé à fonctionner
en septembre c'est en quatre mois et
avec le quart des moyens disponibles que
le fonds a obtenu ces résultats c'est
encore insuffisant
mais cela laisse je crois augurer
favorablement de ce qui va pouvoir être
fait par le maintien des efforts au
cours des semaines et des mois qui
viennent et spécialement en lorraine
puisque le principal de cet effort qui a
été annoncée aujourd'hui est porté sur
le nord alors pour la lorraine est ce
qu'il y aura quelque chose qui suivra
oui c'est principalement sur la lorraine
que nous reste le problème à résoudre
grosso modo si vous voulez en mettant
bout à bout la convention sociale les
effets de la convention sociale que l'on
peut attendre et ce qui a été obtenu par
le fonds spécial adaptation industrielle
en arithmétique
je dis bien à répéter qu'il ya une
restriction là dessus nous trouvons à
peu près la moitié de la solution il
nous reste à trouver l'autre moitié de
la solution et c'est principalement le
problème de longwy qui va être au
premier rang de nos efforts
première réaction de la cgt du nord pas
de calais il ya déjà un très petit
résultat dû à l'action des organisations
syndicales mais c'est très loin de
correspondre aux besoins
dans le même temps on apprenait la
décision de plus de 700 licenciements
dans le groupe creusot loire à rive de
gier
et c'est peut-être tout cela qui
incitait jean pierre fourcade a déclaré
que le gouvernement devait aller
beaucoup plus loin pour lutter contre le
chômage et qu'il fallait créer un impôt
de solidarité nous entendrons l'ancien
ministre dans le journal de pierre-alain
fin de soirée du sang neuf au cnpf
depuis aujourd'hui quatre nouveaux alain
chevalier 47 ans le numéro deux du
groupe moët hennessy
olivier lecerf 49 ans pdg du groupe
cimentier lafarge roger fauroux 51 ans
directeur général de saint gobain
pont-à-mousson et puis laurent
boix-vives 52 ans le patron des skis
rossignol tous ces hommes rentrent dans
les organes dirigeants du patronat dont
le président reste toujours françois
ceyrac et le premier vice président
ambroise des hommes nouveaux
pour de nouvelles orientations black
marino pour comprendre le patronat 79
il va falloir ressortir les vieux
manuels d'histoire et relire la bataille
de crise
souvenez-vous les chevaliers français
des tarifs est protégée par de lourds de
sarm sûrs et s'était fait battre à plate
couture par des fantassins anglais est
souple et léger et bien c'est cette
image que françois ceyrac a choisi ce
matin pour illustrer la nouvelle
orientation du patronat il faut at-il
dit que nos entreprises elles aussi
redeviennent sous légères et libres de
leurs mouvements et cela pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que les pays du
tiers-monde qui entre dans la bataille
économique sont de plus en plus nombreux
ensuite parce qu'à l'horizon en 1981
nous aurons à affronter une véritable
révolution technologique symbolisée par
l'informatique alors pour faire de nos
entreprises des athlètes et non plus de
l'eau chevalier comme à crécy le
pautremat se prépare à lancer une grande
offensive sur notre système de
protection sociale c'est à dire la
sécurité sociale le chômage des
prestations familiales et cetera le
budget social a augmenté de 26% en un an
rappelle les patrons c'est excessif et
cela ne peut pas durer il faut établir
des priorités emploi la famille la
vieillesse et la maladie
il faut clarifier la gestion de la
sécurité sociale bref pour les patrons
on ne peut aborder 1980 sans de
profondes réformes de toute la
protection sociale en politique
maintenant l'annoncé d'une importante
conférence de presse de jacques chirac
le 23 janvier à l'hôtel de ville le
maire de paris président du rpr a dit
ont beaucoup réfléchi pendant ces deux
mois d'immobilisation forcée
cette déclaration de michel pays de ski
toujours chez nos amis disent il serait
normal pour faire face à une situation
très grave qu'éventuellement on puisse
envisager un gouvernement d'union
nationale
et puis ce sondage françois riffaud hop
le chef de l'état a gagnent 2 points
raymond barre ne bouge pas enfin noël
coppens les suite des déclarations de
michel rocard hier soir sur cartes sur
table michel rocard qui disait à ses
vêtements que pierre bombes pourraient
prendre le relais et la succession même
de françois mitterrand à la tête du
parti socialiste
mais la seul et sans entrer dans le
détail des déclarations faites par
michel rocard lui-même et des remous
qu'elles sont si c'était aujourd'hui je
crois qu'on peut retenir ce soir
peut-être quelques certitudes
première certitude il y à bien
maintenant la direction du parti
socialiste deux lignes politiques qui
paraissent de plus en plus
inconciliables deuxième certitude pour
la première fois hier soir françois
mitterrand était mise en cause dans sa
fonction même
de premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste dans l'entourage de françois
mitterrand il estime que les intentions
de michel rocard sont maintenant claires
mais dans l'entourage de michel rocard
ont précisé aujourd'hui que cette
candidature de pierre mauroy au secret
au premier secrétariat du parti n'était
envisagé que s'il y avait un
affrontement
effectivement au congrès troisième
certitude viens je crois qu'on peut dire
que michel rocard a placé quand même
pierre mauroy dans une situation assez
difficile
ce n'est pas tout à fait un démenti que
pierre moreau a publié aujourd'hui nous
l'avons entendu dans notre journal de 13
heures
mais c'était quand même une réaction
assez vives aux propos de michel rocard
et puis quatrième point ce n'est plus
tout à fait une certitude mais c'est du
niveau de dette de l'analyse pierre
mauroy et michel rocard sont
politiquement d'accord mais il ya entre
une différence de tempérament et d'image
l'un michel rocard incarne le mouvement
l'autre pierre mauroy incarne plutôt la
sécurité alors dans ce tandem on aurait
tendance à penser que chacun joue bien
son rôle mais il ya aussi une différence
d'attitude peut-être une analyse pour
pierre mauroy la synthèse reste toujours
possible et il se refuse à prendre
l'initiative d'un affrontement avec
françois mitterrand tandis qu'il semble
bien que pour michel rocard la synthèse
avec françois mitterrand n'est plus
possible d'ici le congrès est qu'au
congrès il y aura forcément un vainqueur
et un vaincu s'il y a quand même une
synthèse à la fin du congrès cette
synthèse se rétablit sur des rapports de
force avant ce congrès une date
importante à retenir la date du 11
février un comité directeur où l'on
verra quels sont les textes qui reste
définitivement en présence c'est à dire
que là on verra s'il ya synthèse ou non
et l'on saura aussi dans quel camp se
situe vraiment pierre moure comité
d'étude a de la chance cela dit pour
l'instant personne ne croit beaucoup à
la synthèse sur la belle écouter à la
fois michel rocard et et françois
mitterrand ce mitterrand je crois que
plus personne maintenant du progrès
trois morts et une vingtaine de blessés
dans un incendie ce matin à paris le
sinistre dont les causes restent
inconnues s'est déclaré au 3e étage d'un
hôtel meublé pour travers immigrés rues
de chalon dans le 12e arrondissement
et quand le feu a pris la panique a
gagné tous les locataires deux d'entre
eux sont d'ailleurs mort après s'être
jetée par la fenêtre rubrique sport avec
du ski toujours en suisse mais adelboden
où s'est disputée ce matin le slalom
géant une course remportée de façon
impériale par le suédois ingemar
stenmark sans doute aiguillonné par sa
contre performance d'hier à crans
montana dans le spécial penser il
n'était que troisième
il ya lui andreas bendel du
liechtenstein et le suisse jacques lüthi
la page de la météo maintenant
aujourd'hui temps froid brumeux mais
bien ensoleillé sur la majeure partie du
pays
demain même temps froid et sec des
nuages sur la manche c'est également sur
le bassin parisien et des chutes de
neige en montagne vers 23h30
pierre-alain prendre à mon relais pour
vous présenter le dernier journal je
vous remercie de votre fidélité et je
vous retrouverai demain avec un très
très grand plaisir vous avez compris que
nous avons un petit peu attendu pour
passer le document dont je vous parlais
je pense me dit on qu'il sera prêt dans
une ou deux minutes c'est pourquoi je
vous propose d'attendre la page de la
publicité et de nous retrouver ensemble
pour passer donc ce document sur la
personnalité du chat le chat qui a
quitté aujourd'hui téhéran pour se
rendre à assouan en egypte
la page de publicité nous nous trouvons
ensuite